and
i just want one person to answer this
girl girl comes over
she's on her phone she's she's staring
at the screen
how do you handle that
okay i guess i'll do it because i'm i'm
the youngest i'm going to hear them
yeah because
yeah so chick if i'm hanging out with a
girl she pulls out her phone must be
hanging out i'll just tell her hey put
that away this is we're gonna it's uh
we're hanging out right now and then oh
sorry most and very rarely
does a girl actually say oh i'm not good
or whatever most of the time she'll
she'll do it you know i mean
it's just that she'll be shocked a
little bit because you called her out
like to do it because
you know we live in a world now where
like chicks are not used to being held
accountable
forever it's hilarious dude who are you
talking to
what was that who you talking to yeah
yeah
countless guys in public places or
restaurants when they were still open
sitting there twiddling their thumbs
while she's staring at her screen for
not seconds but like minutes hammering
away
even swiping sometimes you see the
finger motion right
and they're just sitting there like a
muppet doing nothing
i know it's just uh the thing is this
and and
if you guys uh caught a couple of shows
this week we had two girls come on that
were really high earning only fans girls
right
and the reason why we brought them on
was because we wanted to give guys a
different perspective right
my brain was one of those shows i'm sure
i
lost brain capacity watching those
jupiter as a result of watching that the
thing though this is
this is the thing so uh why i thought it
was so interesting to bring them on was
because they confirmed if you listen
very closely which i tell all the guys
instead of leaving angry comments
underneath the video
watch it with a red lens and you'll see
how many rpg truths are confirmed from
what they say
oh yeah and you know on one side they're
saying oh
just be nice and be confident whatever
all you know they're giving you the
typical you know female
uh i liken a guy but then on one there
and they're like they're like oh yeah
well no i like to get dominated and
everything else like this
so it goes to show like the crazy
disconnect from reality that a lot of
women have
as far as like what they say is
attractive versus what they're actually
attracted to
and then also as well going back to what
rollo says where like a lot of guys
self-deprecate everything like that
the reality is this the reason why guys
self-deprecate and girls
do the girls have a um i guess may
select the way they do is because women
have an over-inflated sense of ego and a
lot of guys have a deflated sense of ego
but in reality man it's cemented to the
prize and the reason why is because
uh i don't know if you guys watch kevin
samuels but you got hundreds of older
women calling into his show asking why
can't i get a high-value guy blah blah
blah
and the cold hard truth is this there's
very few high-value men
there's a lot of women though and all
the women are fighting for the same top
guys but
feminism has lots these women telling
them hey you know what you can have it
all you can have the corporate job just
like john fitch was talking about with
his wife
uh you know you can earn this money
whatever but in reality they end up not
being happy i mean danny banks on the
show talking about yeah i thought
i think about it all the time i'm going
to be single for the rest of my life
this is a girl that's made multi-million
dollars on only fans and she's 30 years
old
but what she still has that you know
innate need to want to have a family to
be able to in a relationship everything
like that because i always say it man
women don't get the same satisfaction
from success that men do
we're built for this they're not but
society tells them that they can do both
and they can't
so having these girls on shows a lot of
light as to like
uh you know these girls are making a lot
of money but are they necessarily happy
who knows right
um but the other thing too also is that
uh i think a lot of guys need to really
understand and like
imprint what rollo was saying when it
says yo i'm the prize
you need to feel happy that you're
around me because the only way a girl is
going to actually
respect you and not want to leave you or
divorce you whatever it is just like
roller said she's got to know that that
doubt of hypergamy is settled and she
knows that she's getting the best
so for her to get that feeling you got
to be congruent in your actions and let
her know hey we're doing this we're
doing that
i'm the prize and honestly let's keep it
real men
are the prize because we have to bring
so much more to the table than women do
like let's just keep it real like women
have a laundry list of requirements they
have on men but men we ask for very few
things
and the thing is is that a lot of these
women they they like
i love watching kevin's show because
what will happen is these women call in
first thing kevin asks them well what
will you provide to a high value guy
bruh all these chicks can't answer
anything oh well i'm really nice all
these subjective terms i'm nice i'm
carrying nurturing
[ __ ] out of here if you were you
wouldn't be 40 and single it's just that
they don't want to hear the harsh
reality
that they're past their time and society
lied to them that oh
now you make six figures you're a strong
independent woman but guess what you're
going to stay independent
so i think guys really need to hammer in
that they are the prize man not the
women
you